la recette fonctionne depuis 1976 les
coureurs s'élanceront ce dimanche 23
septembre à 10h depuis la tour eiffel
pour rejoindre le château de versailles
à l'occasion de la 41e édition du paris
versailles deux lieux symboliques
séparés par 16 km vous avez des 6
premiers kilomètres de faux-plats faut
pas non plus aller trop vite et sans
balais et ensuite vous avez la fameuse
côte des guerres la côte du cimetière
qui est à eux qu un peu mais méconnue
mais qui tient à qui tient son rang qui
tient son rang et puis ensuite vous avez
le faux plat sur l'avenue de paris qui
pour moi le nez plus grande difficulté
puisque vous avez 1 km 500 de faux plats
et une grande largeur de chaussée comme
tous les ans 25 mille coureurs dont 90%
de la région parisienne sont une
nouvelle fois attendus sur l'événement
les inscriptions sont complètes depuis
le mois de juin
pour beaucoup de gens c'est une course
d'entrée de deux jeunes coureurs si
j'ose dire et à tout le monde court un
petit peu puis un jour on court un peu
plus puis on a des copains qui courra
avec soin et puis qui eux sont des
coureurs un peu plus chevronnés eh bien
ils viennent nous vient d'inscrire leur
leurs amis sur cette course-là parce que
c'est ce qui est le maître c'est quand
même relativement court
petite nouveauté cette année les
organisateurs ont créé une application
on pourra voir les temps de passage des
coureurs sur trois secteurs
elle sera disponible à partir du 20
septembre tout semble prêt pour
accueillir la plus grande course à pied
des yvelines